[Music]
we rewrote this this episode four or
five times it was really hard to write
about depression and make it funny and
make it active Ivy's mom who is played
by peri gilpin most popularly known from
Frasier her storyline was depressing too
and it was just hard to make two
storylines about depression funny bill
light I mean the sad lamp and Alana's
heightening of the sad lamp that was one
of our trickier episodes this year and I
I loved it I loved it
but this depression ship SS next level
bitchy kind of digging in my dick is a
little bit hard I hope you never get
better thanks working with RuPaul
Charles was such a dream and finding out
just that he like knows the show and
liked it he plays Marcel who is along
his new boss at this restaurant she's
working on it isn't like a different
character for him to but it also is so
him I think the character is more Stern
than really is containing him into they
can the manager of a restaurant I don't
know what kind of strong Island hongki's
you brought up in here Vuitton yeah but
this is not Billy Joel's go to Dave &
Buster's okay it was just such a crazy
like American honor to have you on our
show I've been watching RuPaul on TV fer
my entire life but to put brew in the
broad city world it it felt so right it
felt like he's been here the whole time
kick me put your foot in my
goddamn you know start again
mm-hmm
it's just such a dream come true
[Music]